[Music]
people don't write [ __ ] up the volume to
raise the volume and hired barely hurt
her and he didn't even hear her it was
just that the whole room got quiet
let's forget she's a mom until she does
that oh my oh that's right that's right
I am a mother okay I'm helping you thank
you Joe
hey I want to tell you a story Joe there
was this guy who painted a pub that is
now being cuz like being remade into
flats in the UK he painted this whole
building and then he said that the guy
who hired him to paint this building
kept adding on these extra tasks before
he could get paid out and so that's when
the painter said you know what [ __ ] you
and he graffiti'd the entire building
and he wrote this a big dick no it's a
video so here we go
he had no option yeah no choice
changing knee pain for jobs online
review sites for customers oh man if I'm
Terry I'm like I [ __ ] love it what
you did esoteric gets it's beautiful so
exactly this painter wrote want your
house painting don't be like Terry pay
the bill
now you will ya know but nobody's gonna
hire this cat because he did this [ __ ]
oh come on man you're hurting your
business but he said that this was the
first job since the new year new year
that he has gotten and so he would work
through his lunches he would work as
fast as he can
to complete this job and then once he
completed it he's claiming that Terry
was said oh no no I'm not gonna pay you
until you take out the gutters and fully
paint the rest of it whatever which was
not something that the painter had
agreed upon once he quoted this man but
then he was like you know what [ __ ] it
I'll just [ __ ] paint it I just want
to get paid I need to pay my bills
I'll [ __ ] do it so he ended up doing
it he and then Terry still didn't pay
him and that's the reason why he says he
resorted to this option of doing the
graffiti on the building because Terry
wouldn't hey but Terry says they did
agree on on those tasks that this
painter ended up saying that oh I'll do
these extra things in order for him to
not complete other jobs that they agree
agreed upon so then the guy who owns the
building says I was gonna pay him
completely like in full once he finished
the job that we agreed on but then he
decided to do this I believe that's his
logic but I don't believe that a painter
doesn't want to just finish his [ __ ]
work right like it sounds like something
a property like I have an uncle who does
contracting and people trying to do this
kind of [ __ ] all the time where it's
like hey can you also do this while
you're here to do this while you're here
do this while you're here this sounds
like some of that kind of [ __ ] yeah
because most people want to do more work
for more pay and better business because
it just that's their job I don't
it just seems logical that why would the
painter one like be like I want to do
more and think of this and this and this
the extra extra gigs and what we
initially agreed to then I have
conscious
well you paint this and then I put I get
paid this yeah I mean no they he does
claim that he had a quote made out to
this man Terry say the name was Dean the
painters Dean so Dean made a quote they
had agreed upon some [ __ ] then Terry
told Dean I will pay you immediately and
then Dean has been like okay there are
some cases though where people are half
asses right and you have to tell them to
make the job normal so they like they'll
[ __ ] half-ass a painting and you're
like what about that [ __ ] corner what
about this you didn't [ __ ] finish
this area and they're like you want me
to do extra work and it's just finish
the damn job you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
people do have definitions of a complete
painting yeah and they're like oh you
want me to do extra my had to charge and
it's like just complete the job the
corners missing this is missing that's
true and I think it's difficult neck is
contracting to it just it's a lot of
gray area a lot it's based off of it's
what they're supposed to do well is give
you an estimate that is accurate to the
the final job but then what ends up
happening is if they don't estimate it
well it'll go over the budget and it
usually always does who usually goes
over the budget yeah and I recently
heard from someone that they've worked
with the contractor and that they got
referred to by neighbors and then that
the job didn't get done and then now
they're suing them and then the other
neighbors are suing them to it that's so
common that sounds so common yeah you
have no clue it's the most common [ __ ]
ever contractors getting sued
countersuing blah blah blah neighbors
joining in blah blah blah neighbors
joining to sue the contractor absolutely
people who had
October by like the same contract and
the three or four neighbors all got
[ __ ] over by the same contracting yard
work down like who's doing your work
neighbor oh cool refer them to me and
they all do it and then they all got
[ __ ] over the same way cuz like one of
the biggest contractor like fraud things
or or scams is they'll start the project
and they a minute they like let's say
drill a big-ass hole in their backyard
they know you're not gonna leave them so
they can start another project or
another project and another project and
now they have everyone's money in line
and they can take however long that they
need to to do all those cool sometimes
it's not a scam but it's a failure to
scale thing because I heard that the
biggest problem for contractors is they
get popular like that and then people
want them to do all these gigs and they
don't know how to manage their time
because they're used to running one or
two homes yeah that's that's and then
all of a sudden they get seven homes and
then they don't know how to scale the
bid they don't know how to say no they
don't know like what the money yeah yeah
yeah and the money they run out of money
quit yeah that's the thing materials are
[ __ ] tons of money right and so they
run out well yeah damn there's just a
lot of issues man I think in LA -
there's a huge demand for contract word
and in so people just need [ __ ] to get
done and then there's not like how you
say like a Yelp for customers and a Yelp
for contractors like that
thank you that's really good that gives
you the reviews of the companies yeah so
yeah you and you use one of the company
you can leave a review and they get put
together with the other reviews of their
companies so you can tell them I know
Amazon started doing one for services
like main service or like people come in
and build shift for you and all that
stuff - with the reviews but reviews
everything right like I use so me and
Nikki have a really sick realtor guide
that we use to buy our our condo and so
then like from him I can get referrals
of like contractor work and [ __ ] like
that like I go I do that because I like
yard work happening like going our guys
[ __ ] awesome so I really really like
him he I think he he was telling he was
like name-dropping some of the neighbors
in the neighborhood that we
like toss Buckley we got like jobs he's
completely I did that house and that
house you go ask oh I will go ask him so
what's go talk to them and go oh don't
worry yeah this guy finish great but way
I had a schedule and like all these
things that were great about him all
cool like his his own customers are
actually satisfied so now he's actually
ahead of schedule
he doesn't charge us until that part
like he can't be puts up the money up
front first he finishes that phase and
then he charges I saw I I love my crazy
[ __ ] buy him some cinnamon rolls we did
and water and cold cinnamon rolls are so
specific give a turkey sandwich we did
Pamela oh we didn't get on that I'm
gonna get him that next you should get
them a honey-glazed ham you know some
fruit - they like yeah a basket of fruit
okay
especially now already don't get the
melon and stuff that's that's because
Geo's people likes orange you do no no
we don't like then we'd like to sell
them oh my bad the mangoes yeah yeah put
the e tie for him L can't do that with
some lime okay now you see if your
contractor was legit or not cuz that was
such a big job their license and we just
googled the license number hey but the
license I heard from another contractor
is it's [ __ ] easy to get and they
don't even know they're [ __ ] some other
times dangerous that's true I guess
that's why it's a dice cool well yeah
that and then I mean we have to get it
approved by the HOA so they look at all
the plans and they say yes or no and
then just referring because he's had
houses there that have like the jobs
been completed for like half a year if
not longer so then we're like how does
how does everything holding up is it
good yeah and like in our neighbor
across the street his house has been
under construction for like six months
before I we moved in it's still under
construction and we're almost done
that's a different person man that guy
gets out he sees your front yard he's
[ __ ] pissed every cut
we're doing for like yeah it's a long
time you're working with other people
and then you're waiting months and
months and months for plans and they can
see other people getting their [ __ ] done
like this cat thought on a Friday he
sees your guy's house he sees your front
yard all [ __ ] up and he's like haha
welcome to the party on Monday he seems
completely done and he's like yeah I
feel bad cuz like I was making fun of
yours yard you know like it's done it's
done it means nothing to me it means
nothing and I was like oh no it means
nothing that's terrible that's terrible
news
let's try to make funny new yard no he
was done that fast not yet
fill it in like with water I like what
the cement it is cement
it's cemented but it's got bowl ready no
it's just one layer the met that makes
it the bowl like it makes it smooth so
there's submit and it there's another
layer that seals the water in they got
to put that under and they fill it up a
water that's like the last last thing
their bucket building a house dude are
you know that's crazy that crazy Oh yard
win Villa house is your's they're
building out you didn't customize the
house no so year round you customize the
house not really I mean the house is
gonna get built anyway we picked out the
aesthetics is it a heated pool yes Oh
fancy pants but yes no all right slowly
no no no this is a lot of track you've
got four panels you can't without it
really it doesn't if you're building a
house you know I feel like you're
building a house when the whole block is
being built yeah it doesn't really
matter your house is built for Casey it
does feel like that but not for me it
just feels like cool look at this
building being built and someday we're
gonna live there I want you to picture
this though that toilet you're gonna
take a [ __ ] in it if the contractor did
yeah exactly
my old apartment building they change
all our toilets out and I was the second
or something you're shittin oh who is
the first [ __ ] brother came over
you ruined it did you know how to weigh
from me that they used to flush toilets
with the poorly thing like that some
bathroom I still got that yeah oh the
pool fine with the water the water
reserve was so taut the reservoir was up
top Denmark and they had that and I'm
having the [ __ ] gravity that's how they
used to flush it I was like what I was
like in Denmark you guys are closer to
Ikea just get a [ __ ]
[Music]